oh man get your diet culture Bingo cards
ready folks cause this is a doozy hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be revisiting our Girl Daisy
Keach and her diet for an alleged
hourglass figure Lord give me strength
you can pause the screen or look at my
description for my general disclaimer
Daisy and I are both going to be
mentioning calories so please feel free
to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and Guys
these are crazy times for YouTubers so
if you haven't already subscribed please
hit that subscribe button ring that Bell
so that you never miss out on videos and
don't forget to follow me on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen first
let me tell you about my sponsor Lily
silk I collaborated with Lily silk
before and have been using their
products ever since they're a favorite
among celebrities like Anne Hathaway and
have been recommended by Forbes for a
reason and let's be real we all love a
good silk moment so I was super excited
about my latest haul okay this is their
100 a grade cashmere turtleneck sweater
so soft and super cozy the fabric work
does not itch your skin and it can be
easily matched with a pair of jeans or a
simple pair of black pants this is their
one size silk tank top it's convenient
to wear as the base with a built-in bra
and it's me with 100 silk knitted fabric
with adjustable straps for the perfect
comfortable fit I am never going to take
this off like literally ever this is
their Chic trimmed silk pajamas I mean I
am always excited about bedtime but I am
extra excited tonight so this is their
beautiful seamless silk fitted sheet and
they're matching pillowcases so the
pillowcases are made of upgraded silk so
they're softer and more elastic than
typical silk they've also got a built-in
compartment which makes it easy to pack
away for traveling it's literally the
best purchase for an amazing sleep
experience and I love the feeling on my
skin like I may never leave bed so if
you want to find some amazing pieces for
holiday gifts especially during the
holiday sale check out the link in my
description and use my promo code
abbeysharp 12 to get 12 off site-wide
okay I was really trying to bury the
hatchet with our friend Daisy Keach like
really really trying but then this had
to show up in my feed I was triggered my
team was triggered we all felt it was
time to react when I eat in a day for an
hourglass body I'm just gonna stop you
right there Daisy nothing you eat will
give you an hourglass figure you can't
decide where fat wants to migrate on
your body virtually all the research on
spot reduction has been done using
exercise programs not diet and even that
research makes it clear that targeting
fat loss in a specific area is very
unlikely like I know this is Click bait
but then just like make a click bait
don't reinforce it in the video Itself
by saying this is what I eat for an
hourglass figure your body is either
genetically prone to an hourglass shape
or you get surgery like those are
basically your options but I have mango
raspberries blueberries and pineapple
and then a bunch of local honey on top
and this is the brand of sausage I think
it's just chicken sausage no casein 13
grams of protein and no antibiotics
okay this looks delicious
um I looked these sausages up and they
look like pretty great high protein
options but this meal is pretty Locale
like probably 300 calories Max with
maybe five grams of fat so I definitely
think there's some room in here for some
extra carbs and some healthy fats to
bulk this up I don't like to just roll
with the system I like to figure out
what's going on in this world with our
diets and the farms and all that kind of
stuff I'm kind of crazy honestly kind of
psycho this is just a friendly reminder
that being obsessed with the food system
and our diets to the point of being kind
of psycho about it is a really slippery
slope this is literally the definition
of orthorexia which is a potentially
deadly eating disorder so it's really
not something that we should be
glamorizing or treating as a flex but
this one is sweetened with agave nectar
and it's really going to honestly tastes
the same and to me like after I have
like regular ketchup I like feel kind of
sick and gross but after this like it
just tastes good and I feel good after
if Daisy prefers The Taste or how she
feels from her ketchup of choice amazing
it's great that we have so many options
these days but to make such a fuss over
like an Agave sweetened sauce over one
Sweden with high fructose corn syrup
feels a little short-sighted most of the
criticism around high fructose corn
syrup is that it's high in fructose
which has been linked to chronic disease
since our liver is the only organ that
can metabolize fructose in significant
amounts but if this was the only issue
Agave may actually be a bigger threat
since Agave actually contains more
fructose so about 85 percent of its
total sugar content while the most
commonly used variety of high fructose
corn syrup in our food system high
fructose corn syrup to 55. actually has
a fructose to glucose ratio similar to
like table sugar and also pretty close
to Honey And while yes there is some
research to suggest that the unique
combination of glucose and fructose may
have a particularly dangerous
synergistic effect a recent review of
the literature found that fructose or
high fructose corn syrup actually had no
measurable differences on cardio
metabolic markers when compared to just
glucose or sucrose in other words
obsessing over what sweetener is in your
ketchup is likely missing the forest
from the trees most people aren't eating
ketchup like every day as a snack it's a
[ __ ] dip if you're enjoying it in
moderation in the context of a varied
diet I really don't think it matters
that much which you choose that was one
thing I noticed in Europe too they
regulate the ingredients a lot more and
the same brand of ketchup had different
ingredients in Europe than it does here
in the states like it's just so crazy oh
boy here we go
you ready this is a massive massive
topic that really requires a whole video
to unpack but very very very short just
because something is banned in the EU or
not approved in Europe doesn't mean it's
necessarily bad Europe and the US just
use different approaches when it comes
to approving a food or additive Europe
uses a hazard approach which looks at
something that has the potential to
cause harm and the United States uses a
risk approach which considers the hazard
plus exposure my colleague food science
babe uses formaldehyde as a really good
example to explain the differences in
these approaches we know that
formaldehyde can be toxic to humans but
it's also naturally found in apples and
pears and our bodies also just like
naturally produce it should we ban
apples and pears in the states I would
hope not because ultimately the dose
makes the poison so a risk approach
would consider the evidence on how much
of an ingredient or food would be likely
to cause harm not just theoretically or
potential anyway again this is a huge
topic and I'm not saying that one way of
Regulation is better than the other
they're just different but I highly
recommend food science babes resources
on this topic if you want to learn more
you know stay away from the inflammatory
oils like seed oils so everything that
I'm eating today is seed oil free I feel
like we've gone over this a lot but okay
get at me so while some Studies have
pointed to the potential inflammatory
properties of too much omega-6 in the
diet the larger body of high quality
evidence suggests that omega-6 fats do
not have a significant effect on
inflammation in fact a 2012 systematic
review assessed the effects of omega-6
linoleic acid on inflammatory markers
like C-reactive protein cytokines and
tumor necrosis factor and found no
strong link to suggests that it
increased inflammation there's even some
research that omega-6s may even be
associated with a reduced risk of
cardiovascular events so repeat after me
folks the dose makes the poison choose a
variety of fats in your diet to get the
best varied fatty acid profile to reduce
the risk of overdoing it on anything
specific so here I have my cake and
water
it basically is this machine that
alkalizes water it's supposed to be
really good for you so that's what I'm
doing and I also have my chlorophyll
drops oh my gosh this video is honestly
the gift that just keeps on giving I
told you guys to get your bingo cards
out because this is a real winner
Bingo okay very very fast alkaline water
does nothing to change your body pH if
it did Daisy would die we did have one
small lab study suggesting that alkaline
water might help to prevent acid reflux
by deactivating the stomach enzyme
pepsin but too much alkaline water could
also theoretically lower stomach acid
which is not ideal as stomach acid is
important for digestion and also
eliminating bacteria the hype around
chlorophyll on the other hand seems to
be based on a few small studies which
suggested that it can help to clear up
your skin and reduce the signs of aging
but all these studies looked at
chlorophyll as a topical skin treatment
and not as something that you ingest in
a little bit of water if you're eating
green things folks you're getting your
chlorophyll fish
next so this is natural she legit but it
basically is supposed to contain a lot
of minerals that make up your body and
our soils are depleted of minerals so
we're not getting the right nutrients
and minerals that we need for our bodies
to be able to heal themselves and to be
healthy so I take about this much we are
still going folks wow this girl is like
testing my research knowledge all right
Sheila heat is a very mineral dense yes
but we don't have a lot of evidence on
its use in humans so there is some
animal or exploratory research going on
for brain health male infertility heart
health and iron deficiency anemia as for
the soils are depleted of nutrition
these days claim this is just such a
huge topic but based on the best quality
of research that we have spanning over
175 years that looked specifically at
wheat crops we can see that well
nutrient content has declined it's not
due to the soil it's more likely due to
yield dilution with the shift towards
more High yielding modern crops during
the Green Revolution of the 1960s so
yeah there's your little mini food
history lesson of the day but long story
short I recommend everyone should go get
their blood tested and see what they're
lacking and what they need finally
something we can agree on so this video
is sponsored by Celsius there's no
artificial flavors or coloring I need to
pick me up it's like the middle of the
day I'm starting a little bit sleepy I
don't care how or when you take your
caffeine if you want to drink it as a
Celsius you do you but could it be
possible that we need a pick-me-up in
the middle of the day because we've only
had a small meal and a ton of
supplements thus far folks even though
caffeine can give us the sensation of
energy the only real form of energy is
from calories in food okay now I'm
having a little sec I'm just having this
pretzel chocolate protein bar it has 12
grams of protein 25 carbs and six fat
and there's no inflammatory seed oils in
here this bar sounds delicious but we
could also just say it's delicious or
that it gives you energy or it helps you
recover from a workout like not
everything needs to come with like a
food fear-mongering lecture I'm going to
have some organic grass-fed kefir okay
now I am eating my lunch and I just have
my
chicken and vegetable soup that I made
it is cold as here in Canada so this is
giving me lots of cozy food feels but a
bowl of broth with some veggies and
chicken bits in it and a glass of kefir
is not really an adequate meal for the
vast majority of adult women this is
like Max 250 calories for lunch well
below what I would recommend for a meal
even if you're trying to actively lose
weight and I would hate for young
impressional viewers to see this and
think oh great I just need to eat a big
low calorie broth based soup as a meal
to get an hourglass figure no like just
know so if you're watching this and
you're craving soup know that this
dietitian thinks that you can have it
with some avocado toast or a sandwich or
a wrap or really any other source of
carbs okay so I'm having a super late
dinner because I had a really late lunch
so this is my new obsession right here
these cauliflower
chicken nuggets basically it's like a
chicken tender but breaded and
cauliflower in the entire bag it is 490
calories that's it six grams of fat 49
grams of carbs zero sugar obviously and
65 grams of protein in an entire bag
usually like if I did a booty day I
would have had a carb
um like a rice or something like that
right after my workout
um and then I would have had a protein
shake wow
we got a lot to unpack so first of all
let's make it super clear that you never
need to earn carbs or calories by doing
a booty day I spoke to my colleague Eric
Williamson about this and he told me
that if you're exercising recreationally
so around 60 Minutes or Less a day you
don't need to reduce your calories or
carbs on rest days your nutrition over
time is a lot more important for
Performance Health and body comp than a
specific day as for the meal itself when
Daisy read out the macros for the whole
bag at being 490 calories I was feeling
kind of hopeful that we would actually
get an average healthy sized meal but
then she makes herself like four or five
like a 250 calorie meal with nothing on
the side somebody make it make sense
four or five chicken tenders would be a
great protein element to a meal but even
without the booty day I would love to
see some carbs and fiber-rich veg like I
just realized that we really haven't had
very many vegetables in this day maybe a
small little Handful in the soup and for
someone so committed to maintaining an
impossibly lean figure I'm truly
surprised that there isn't a greater
emphasis on fiber rich fruits and veg
now I honestly rarely discuss calorie
counts anymore because I know that it
can be triggering for a lot of folks so
please skip ahead if that sounds like
you but this day had maybe 1100 calories
I don't care if Daisy sat on her ass all
day and all the days before that grown
ass women need more calories than that
and coupled with the promise of an
hourglass figure plus a million Shady
Wellness culture hacks this is up there
with like the most problematic wedding
in a day videos I've reviewed in a while
so please folks do not repeat and on
that note that is all that I can manage
today without getting another coffee or
something stronger so if you like this
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with your thoughts on
what or who you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]